[Music]
[Applause]
happy Wednesday
everyone yeah yeah control
yourselves so remember back in grade
school when the teacher would leave the
room and tell everyone to behave while
she was gone of course the second she
left the room went wild it's how I got
my first tattoo I'd show you but the FCC
doesn't allow frontal
nudity so it was great with the teacher
gone right but remember how after a
while it would get up ugly the bullying
and the fights would start things would
get tossed around the room and by things
I mean
me so when the teacher came back you
were sort of relieved in your heart you
knew the class needed a grownup to keep
things from chaos which brings us to
America can someone please call the
teacher back into the room and not so
they can sleep with their students
although that helps but to save us from
the madness every weekend we're seeing
the same stories of violent mobs
disrupting and D destroying our cities
it makes me remember the good old days
when it used to be safe to poop in the
street meanwhile our colleges are
handing out extra credit for
intimidating and assaulting Jewish
students and shoplifting has become as
lucrative for unskilled people as guest
hosting the Daily
Show it's true though our media and
government are cheering this chaos like
they're in the audience at the view
enjoy bayar just threw him sardines so
at this point can I just ask a simple
question is anyone actually running this
place or is it all by Design because
nothing goes wrong this perfectly let's
take Atlanta last week two BLM rioter
were allowed to take a plea deal for
burning down a Wendy's restaurant talk
about flame
broiling the two arsonists Chism
Kingston and Natalie white each received
a $500 fine and probation that's right
no jail time for first deegree arson
I'll remember that the next time I go
through a drive-thru in when they forget
my
ketchup but I guess that's why they call
it
hotlanta or they used to I don't
remember the arson occurred after black
man suspected of a DWI got into a
scuffle with police the man got hold of
one of the cops tasers fired twice which
is when the officer shot and killed him
and the and amid the ongoing protests
after someone shot and killed an
8-year-old black girl near the site a
few weeks later now this was during 2020
Summer of Love when rioter Nationwide
engaged in mostly peaceful protest that
did $2 billion in damage and killed at
least 19 people it used to be to get
that kind of love you had to change your
safe word to
harder so how do these two firebugs get
a deal so sweet it should have come with
a shot of insulin well here's Fanny
Willis the Atlanta Chief prosecutor
she's doing such a great job on crime
down there that Atlanta's Buckhead
region which accounts for 40% of the
city's tax revenue is actually trying to
secede at least Fanny saved KLA the
trouble of having to bail the two
arsonist out so after the Wendy's became
a smoking ruin the site became yet
another BLM Shrine and occupied Zone you
know just like Chaz the autonomous Zone
in Seattle where protesters took over
the area around Seattle's East Precinct
after six shootings in a little over a
week the Chaz was finally cleared out
and just like the area around George
Floyd's Square the intersection renamed
after Floyd's death that worked out
great too last month store owners and
George Floyd Square sued the City of
Minneapolis claiming that the area has
become a hub for violent crime and that
police won't even respond anymore
strange how powerful those three letters
are
BLM they seem to instantly put
prosecutors to sleep faster than a rum
and coke from Bill
Cosby in fact one major study found that
the vast majority of charges against BLM
protesters in the summer of 2020 were
ultimately dropped or dismissed and of
course massive fraud by BLM itself has
never been investigated so wait a minute
if nobody's holding anyone to account
for all this what is our Criminal
Justice System actually doing well
there's Fanny down at Atlanta who's
keeping busy with her 13c count Rico on
Donald Trump which has to be the most
bogus case since Prince Prince Harry
claimed he had
balls that was unnecessary oh and
there's always Jan 6 the most persecuted
Jan since Eve
plum our feds just can't go to that well
often enough can they currently over
12200 people have been charged many for
just setting foot on the capital steps
take for instance this man seaka masoy
nearly three years after the fact the
feds just picked him up charged with
misdemeanors including trespassing
disorderly conduct and parading in a
capital building parading three years of
Investigation for that countless manh
hours for this guy why do I get the
feeling cak's major felonies are being a
trump supporter and a conservative on
social media Congressman Mike Collins
who represents an area near Atlanta put
it this way quote I'm sure a lot of j6
trespassers would love to pay $500 and
go home if only they had burned down a
building
maybe I know got the biggest laugh hire
that guy we need writers so while the
feds and Progressive prosecutors obsess
on Trump Jan 6 and the ongoing plague of
pronoun misuse Jewish students on campus
still feel unsafe and we know that not
because of Any prosecution or arrests
but because of Republican Le hearings on
Capitol Hill yesterday meanwhile with
the weekend coming up the current crop
of anti-israel riers made up heavily of
antifa and BLM rebrands will again shut
down traffic and trains and commit
random acts of violence and vandalism
and there will be no consequences is it
me or does it look like the teacher
won't be back in the room until November
2024 that's only if he's not locked in
the faculty room by the
administrators let's
welcome tonight's guest he's hairy and
his impressions are scary actor in stand
of comedian Tyler
fiser he's done more triggering than an
epileptic at a shooting range lawyer in
toown hall.com senior colum this skirt
schlicker she's like a poptart a sugary
treat that can fit in the toaster New
York Times bestselling author and foxus
contributor cat
Tib and he eats his dinner with a knife
and fork lift New York Times bestselling
author comedian and former NWA world
champion
[Applause]
[Music]
Tyrus Tyler I get the sense that our
country is in a moral quandry we're like
in this new world where the rules that
we used to live by no longer exist makes
me think of the great philosopher Jordan
Peterson I wonder what he would have to
say about this well you know probably
start crying get a little emotional you
know you know well I think he might have
sympathy for the uh the guy that burned
down that Wendy's you know cuz it's like
well if you're hanging out at Wendy's
maybe $500 is a lot of money to you you
know it's like maybe that's 335 Junior
cheeseburgers you know and uh maybe if
he cleaned his damn room got his life
together and he wouldn't pick up a match
you know it's like well you know that's
about all I have to say about that Greg
what does Tyler think I think that uh
yeah I mean look it's a it's a double
standard you know double cheeseburger
double standard and uh I think $500 is a
lot of money for somebody who's broke so
you know I hey when I was a new actor a
new comedian that would have killed me
yeah that's true so I say make him work
the drive-thru for a year at 2: in the
morning he'll never do it again yeah
that's true you know Kurt you're a
lawyer you claim to be a lawyer I'm
pretty sure you are a lawyer right well
sort of yes sort of uh do you think
there's a double standard here I know
there's a double standard you know
people are continually asking me Greg
what is your legal opinion about all
these things and I don't have a legal
opinion about it because it has nothing
to do with law it's the exact opposite
of law when I go to court on a regular
case you know so and so ran over so and
so yeah you present facts you have law
judge makes a ruling it's all normal and
then I see this insanity this lunacy
where where where you know $500 for
burning down a
Wendy's look maybe that's on target it's
a Wendy's if it's a Jack in a box they
actually give him money and if it was
and if it was an In-N-Out he'd have to
be hunted for sport yes um but no no
there there there's a complete double
standard I mean there's some Grandma
somewhere who took selfies in the
Rotunda and she's doing hard time on a
chain gang yeah you know and this pair
is going yeah here's 500 bucks for my
dad's trust fund let's go MH yeah it's
it's an outrage cat do have we become a
country that now has political prisoners
because that's what it feels like we
have people in jail because they were on
the wrong side of an election well I've
never really understood these kind of
comparisons between you know the setting
building on fire versus January 6
because you know going into the building
whatever disorderly conduct in the
building is a different than setting it
on fire and then also the capital is a
lot different than a Wendy's in a lot of
different ways but looking at them
individually right the Wendy's $500 fine
for setting it on fire actually back in
2020 that was a fine you could face for
breaking lockdown rules Co lockdown
rules would be $500 I feel like going
out with your friends or having a
restaurant that's open should be treated
differently than burning one um but also
I've talked a lot on this show and
elsewhere about you know over
incarceration of nonviolent crimes and
I'd be a total hypocrite to talk about
all that regardless I mean January 6 was
bad bad decision to go in that building
for sure but to say that an appropriate
response when what you're being charged
with the highest thing that you're being
charged with really is like what
disorderly conduct in the capital to
have to be picked up by FBI agents at
the airport and taken to jail that is
obviously um a a punishment and being
treated in a way that does not fit a
handful of misdemeanors it doesn't fit
at all Tyrus that took them three years
to NAB this guy what were they doing
they had people devoted to fighting this
guy yeah Greg it does fit it fits
perfectly what we're what we're seeing
in this country is we have two court
systems and how it works was it used to
be rich and poor like if you had money
for a real expensive lawyer you get a
couple lawyers you defend now all you
have to do is your crime has to fit The
Narrative of who the da is so if if
you're a left leaning criminal you don't
pull in Alabama yeah you do it in towns
where you know that the that the that
the uh ad is the attorney general or the
or the district attorney uh they're left
leaning because you're going to get
treated like they're not going to hurt
the cause because it used to be when you
got arrested and went to jail it was
deterrent not just for you for everybody
else so if and they're saying they just
burnt down a Wendy's no no they cost
about 45 people their jobs yeah proper
damage would be in the millions who's
responsible for that because it used to
be if you did something if I hit a
baseball and broke the window I had to
pay for the window yeah you know what
I'm saying but now as long as what I did
was in the purview of whomever is in
power and we we saw that in the in the
George Floyd trial where if it's a
left-leaning judge he's going to make
he's going to protect the narrative
instead of the people so we're seeing a
real change in law to where and your
point was 100% it wasn't law it was
there on the right side so that da is
going to give him a a $500 fine but you
know what they did they just inspired
the next group so if I'm sitting there
with a cocktail in my hand and I go to
light it my friend goes hey don't do
that why they're going to pay my 500
bucks for me you want one yeah why not
so they're just saying as long as it's
in the cause as long as you're in line
with BLM and these and these left
leaning or in the same case you could
make it the right side too we saw that
in the 50s in in the 60s now it's on the
left so as long as you're in line you're
good and you'll be continued to go on
and that's the part that scary that is
scary hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else